ми всі боремося за свободу і боремося за
життя українців слова хейтерів з Росії
безглузді
ви сказали цитую якщо росіяни на нас
зляться Значить ми добре робимо свою
роботу Саме так мене не турбує Що вони
говорять мене не турбує громадська думка
мене не турбує обурення належність до
лгбтк не визначає мене як людину війна
для кожного Хто розуміє свободу
американка Сара Ештон сіріло приїхала в
Україну у березні 2022 року як
журналістка згодом підписала контракт із
ЗСУ останнім часом вона працювала у
медіа команді sille територіальної
оборони і записували відео для іноземної
аудиторії вона стала першою
трансгендерною жінкою яка виконувала
таку роль в українському війську за добу
після того як ми записали інтерв'ю з
Сарою Ештон сіріло її відсторонили від
виконання обов'язків як заявили у силах
тероборони через те що деякі слова у
відео які публікує Сара не були
погоджені з командуванням з приводу
цього розпочато розслідування у нашому
інтерв'ю Сара ештонсеріло коментує
зокрема із своїм неоднозначні
висловлювання які слова могли стати
приводом для її відсторонення чому Вони
викликали хвилю хейту в Росії і яке
ставлення до себе Сара як трансгендерка
відчуває в Україні
Дякую що погодилися на розмову з ДВ
неймовірно рада бути тут Анно Дуже дякую
по-перше знаю що ви щойно повернулися з
поїздки на схід України ви були близько
до лінії фронту що ви там побачили що у
вас найбільше вразило
Найбільше мене вразило перебування на
Схід і на північ від Куп'янська Ми
бачили як Українські сили оборони
впевнено тримають лінію оборони від
російських окупантів тепер ми розуміємо
чому чуємо від наших командирів
повідомлення про те що Росії потрібно
перегрупуватися бо врешті-решт попри
розміщення майже 100 тисяч солдатів на
ділянці мішкуп'янськими лиманом Росія не
змогла прорвати українські лінії оборони
нині річниця Харківського контрнаступу
тому ми вирушили туди щоб побачити
успіхи яких досягають Українські сили
оборони вони показують чому питання не в
тому чи перемога а в тому коли вона буде
ви були там рік тому
[музика]
я була напевно першою цивільною особою
яка побувала в куп'янській мерії після
звільнення а також провела три дні в
лимані спостерігаючи за ексгумацією тіл
жертв терору і геноциду здійснених
російськими загарбниками тож під час
Контр наступу я значну частину часу
провела на сході
[музика]
поговоримо про вашу публічну роботу я
маю на увазі регулярні відео публікації
під назвою Росія ненавидить правду та
будьте в курсі України ви пояснюєте
війну в Україні іноземній аудиторії я
переглядала коментарі до відео чимало з
них англійською мовою і не всі глядачі
підтримують Україну
багато коментаторів Це просто залишки
ферми тролів пригожина та учасники
інформаційної війни Путіна і пригожина
проти України Ця інформаційна війна
почалася не 9 з половиною років тому
інформаційна війна почалася незабаром
після того як Україна проголосила
незалежність від Радянського Союзу і
Росія хотіла вплинути на людей на сході
ми це знаємо команда комунікаційників
сил територіальної оборони знаходиться
на передовій інформа війни тож Коли я
бачу як люди виступають проти України
якщо вони не наводять мені конкретних
причин заснованих на фактах а не
російських ТЕС я їх ігнорую тому що
зрештою хоча свобода слова це все це не
означає що будь-які слова є розумними
інтерв'ю ви сказали цитую якщо росіяни
на нас зляться Значить ми добре робимо
свою роботу Саме так чого ви
сподіваєтеся досягти завдяки відео які
ви робите і злості яку вони викликають
зокрема у росіян
дуже відомий росіянин якщо не помиляюся
він росіянин Павлов проводив
експерименти з собаками і тут у
медіа-студії сил територіальної оборони
ми розуміємо що теорія Павлова працює
коли ми публікуємо відео налітають
росіяни відео це теж саме що і дзвіночки
Павлова тому коли ми разом з командою
публікуємо інформацію ми розуміємо що
якщо вона приверне увагу росіян
розлютить їх і вони процитують себе
скрегочуть зубами це значить що ми
ефективні тому що це дозволяє уникнути
нападів на наше керівництво зрештою якщо
ненависть Росія заливається на мене тому
що Росія ненавидить правду Це означає що
ті хто є більш важливими в цій країні
менше піддаються нападам Це моя мета
відвернути вогонь від нашого керівництва
водночас відкривши західні аудиторії
правду про те що відбувається тут в
Україні і що відбувається всередині
Росії з їхньою пропагандою та їхніми
геноцидними тенденціями
Як ви описуєте здається що це дуже важка
робота Як ви справляєтеся З усією
ненавистю негативними коментарями
погрозами на вашу адресу
ми всі боремося за свободу і боремося за
життя українців слова хейтерів з Росії
безглузді я була на передовій усі Мої
колеги були на передовій і не тільки як
журналісти ми воювали на фронті Ми
бачили життя і ми бачили смерть слова не
мають значення коли ти розумієш що
своїми діями сприятимеш не тільки
визволенню України а й порятунку життів
і українців і росіян бо Володимир Путін
чинить геноцид не лише українців він
також вчиняє геноцид росіян
відео де стверджували цитую що
російських пропагандистів воєнних
злочинців вистежать так
злочинців вистежать правосуддя переможе
адже ми в Україні виконуємо цю місію з
допомогою віри в Бога свободу і повне
звільнення
це відео викликало бурхливу реакцію не
лише в Росії але і у США на них звернув
увагу зокрема сенатор республіканець
Джеймс венс врешті їх обговорювали і На
американському телебаченні Ось як свої
слова у відео Сара ештонсеріло
прокоментувала у нашому інтерв'ю
Що про це думає ваше командування
через роботу СБУ а також міжнародних
трибуналів і національної поліції тут в
Україні ще пропагандистів почали
заарештовувати ми розуміємо що в нас в
Україні вже судять пропагандистів і є
чіткі закони яких треба дотримуватися
тож хоча люди можуть скреготіти зубами
та червоніти від люті через мої заяви я
не відмовлюся від своїх слів воєнні
злочинці повинні бути знайдені
притягнені до відповідальності у нас є
міжнародні трибунали були деякі заяви що
під російськими пропагандистами вимали
на увазі журналістів ви мали на увазі
російських журналістів якщо хтось є
журналістом Він має повне право на всі
механізми захисту тобто з точки зору
писаних і неписаних законів журналістики
але ці російські пропагандисти
інформаційні воїни вони не журналісти і
фактично кожен журналіст має засуджувати
те що роблять їхні так звані російські
колеги адже таким людям як скабєєва
Соловйов симоньян та іншим місце в гаазі
Чому ви думаєте що ваша кандидатура
підходить для цієї роботи
це гарне запитання Чому я відповідаю цій
посаді
можливо тому що я розумію Що росіяни
насправді просто влаштували виставу
тому якщо ми ставимося до них як до тих
хто влаштував цю Криваву виставу Ми
можемо побачити їх такими якими вони є і
я це бачу
крім того мене не турбує Що вони
говорять мене не турбує громадська думка
мене не турбує обурення по всьому світу
Люди з приводу чогось обурюються 24
години на добу це частина цілодобового
потоку новин у якому Ми зараз живемо не
можна перейматися через обурення і
брехню вигадану росіянами і оскільки Я
не сприймаю це близько до серця я вважаю
що ця робота мені підходить
крім того дуже важливим є розуміння того
як працюють росіяни з аналітичної точки
зору
Я маю справу з російською дезінформацією
займаюся аналітичною роботою а також
виступає на камеру розповідає чи про це
людям я виконую свою роботу на високому
рівні і що не всі могли б відповідати
цій ролі
Я б сказала що моя командування
задоволене нашою роботою Я визнаю що у
командувачів іноді голови болять через
те що я говорю Але вони розуміють що цей
ефективно медіагрупи сил територіальної
оборони є найкращою командою для
інформаційної боротьби в країні Я дуже
пишаюся іншими моїми колегами які
виконують свою роботу на фронті
інформаційної війни але я чітко заявляю
що Наша команда не має собі рівних коли
справи доходить до виробництва контенту
а також нашої аналітичної роботи є
ви працювали журналістом журналістом
фрілансером чи вважаєте ви те що зараз
робите пропагандою
Я вважаю це передовою інформаційної
війни Пропаганда - це коли ти вигадуєш
історії ми повідомляємо правду з
медіа-студії сил територіальної оборони
тепер під час війни правда може бути
лише з одного боку і на щастя я на боці
країни яка говорить правду Тому ні це не
Пропаганда це новини подані в іншому
більш унікальному форматі але точно не
Пропаганда
Росія почала повномасштабний вторгнення
українці стали більш толерантними до
лгбтк-спільноти це видно За опитуваннями
але останнє опитування яке я бачила
проводилося в червні цього року і
говорить про те що 34% українців Все ще
відчувають і негативне ставлення до
лгбтк Як трансгендерка ви коли-небудь
відчували це
особисто ніколи очевидно я читала заяви
про мене в інтернеті але як ми вже
говорили раніше Якщо хтось хоче написати
щось про мене в інтернеті це його вибір
знову ж таки Свобода слова мене це не
турбує Якщо хтось хоче обговорити
питання
лгбтк хоча це не є моїм пріоритетом вони
можуть поговорити зі мною але належність
до лгбтк не визначає мене як людину з
першого дня тут в Україні а це було 5
березня 2022 року у мене ніколи не було
досвіду негативного спілкування ні з ким
з армії ні з ким у моєму командуванні ні
з людьми з якими я працювала зокрема
перебуваючи на фронті чи тут в Києві
простіше кажучи це не було проблемою
тепер зрештою я усвідомлю що все дуже
змінилося за останні два роки Я знаю що
відбувалося до цього І я чула підвищення
про те що відбувалося але виглядає так
ніби Зараз країна зосереджена виключно
на перемозі а люди сповнені ідей свободи
та звільнення Я заявляю знову і знову І
я буду повторювати це до Дня нашої
повної Перемоги ми не боремося за
толерантність чи прийняття будь-якої
групи людей ми боремося за визволення та
свободу всіх людей в Україні та на всій
земній кулі тому так необхідно перемогти
російських тиранів
як журналіст Ви писали Про лгбтк
військових в Українській армії якою є
ситуація для них зараз у них є проблеми
ви знаєте я чула розповіді про проблеми
але навіть у моїх репортах була одна
історія про те як підрозділ Азов
працював з Ukraine pride коли вони були
в Маріуполі і Ukraine pride збирав гроші
їм на рації
лгб Т спільнота має неймовірне охоплення
особливо за допомогою організованих груп
таких як Ukraine pride київпрайд Харків
Прайд Дженнер стрім українських
організацій які підтримують військових і
ідею визволення України
тому на мою думку військові усвідомлюють
що
ЛГБТ спільнота їх підтримує
ЛГБТ спільнота розуміє що ми всі
боремося заповни звільнення
коли мова заходить про самих військових
які належать до лгбтк Хоча я чула
неофіційні свідчення Ніхто з тих у кого
як коли-небудь брала інтерв'ю не
виступав із такими твердженнями кожен
хто служить дуже пишається тим що
служить Україні
Що може зробити Україна щоб
стаю до лгбтк треба спостерігати за
ситуацією і законопроєктом щодо
одностатевих шлюбів це те про що я як
військовослужбовець Збройних Сил України
не можу говорити тому що це відбувається
у внутрішньополітичній сфері але
очевидно що якщо такий закон буде
ухвалений пройде це буде вигідно
багатьом солдатам які служать на фронті
приїхали в Україну Ви очікували на таке
позитивне ставлення до лгбтк до
трансгендерних людей
звісно ні ви знаєте коли я приїхала сюди
Я знала що Росія жахлива
я знала що Росія - це чорна діра
терористична держава але є дійсно не
знала багато про Україну
окрім помаранчевої революції Майдану
Вторгнення в Крим і боїв на Донбасі
але я не знала суспільних поглядів є
уявляла що вони набагато толерантніший
за ті що в Росії але все ж думала що
вони не надто толерантні і коли я
приїхала сюди Я побачила дуже
лібертаріанський стиль життя є свої
цінності традиційні цінності Але в цьому
суспільстві ти маєш право як людина жити
своїм життям так як вважаєш за потрібне
І це те за що ми боремося щоб люди були
вільними і тому я була приємно здивована
коли побачила що якщо ви поважаєте
культуру і цінності країни ви отримаєте
особисто свободу і це було просто
дивовижне відкриття
що у вас спонукало приїхати сюди в
Україну я їхала на два тижні щоб писати
пробіжинців і все два тижні і я
збиралася повернутися додому до
політичного життя невади Я все ще люблю
невадо я все що Вважаю лас-вегас домом
це офіційно мій дім але через 19 місяців
я все що тут і це частково пов’язано з
тим що я розуміла що якщо ми не виграємо
війну вона вплине на всіх у цьому світі
уявляли себе у війську
ніколи я приїхала сюди не для того щоб
служити в армії Я приїхала насамперед
щоб написати книжку а потім коли випала
нагода поїхала до Харкова щоб робити з
передовою репортажі про війну чому я
опинилася на службі тому що після 6,5
місяців у Харківській області бачила
російський геноцид російський тероризм
російські воєнні злочини щодня коли я
почала працювати в золочівській громаді
з мером коваленком Я багато часу провела
біля російського кордону в російській
прикордонній зоні я бачила такі жахливі
жахливі вчинки вони просто вбивали мирне
населення щотижня коли ти бачиш смерть у
Харкові наражаєш себе на небезпеку то
розумієш що хочеш і маєш зробити щось
більше і нарешті після того що я
побачила в Ізюмі Я сказала що готова
піти на службу деякі розмови про це
почалися ще в кінці липня всередині
серпня мені пропонували вступити до
війська після ізюму я зрозуміла що треба
вступати у мене не було вибору
люди дусі вважають що війна не для жінок
щоб ви їм відповіли
у нас понад 5 тисяч жінок служать на
передовій у нас близько 10% армії
збройних сил України жінки війна для
кожного Хто розуміє свободу
війна страшна і найкращий спосіб для
будь-якого чоловіка чи жінки зупинити
війну це взяти участь як волонтер або як
журналіст або як солдат або як той хто
створює податкові надходження а це
означає що і чоловіки і жінки виконують
свою роль
жінки які хочуть бути на фронті і які
здатні бути на фронті можна служать
країні та визволенню
тож хоча деякі вважаючи жінок там бути
не повинно вибір понад 5 тисяч жінок
говорить сам за себе
я знаю Ще двох трансгендерів які як і я
служать в Українській армії принаймні
двох я знаю що можливо є ще двоє вони
дещо публічні одна з проблем що
стосується транслюдей полягає в тому щоб
вирішити медичні моменти пройти
психологічні тести мені довелося пройти
психологічний медичне тестування так
само і двом транслюдям про яких я
говорила і які служать ми просто люди у
військових немає іншої ідентичності крім
того що вони військові
за розмову зд
в і Дякую що завітали до нашої студії
Анну